in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about ocean
acidification
and as we'll see it's all related to
increased carbon dioxide concentrations
in the atmosphere and we have talked
about this in other videos but we can
see if we look at carbon dioxide
concentrations over the last 800 000
years which is well before modern human
beings existed
it has oscillated between roughly 200
parts per million and 300 parts per
million but then if we look at modern
times the spike has gone well beyond
that range and this axis right over here
it's covering so much time it might not
be obvious when or why the spike has
happened so let's zoom in a little bit
on the last several hundred years or so
and when you do that this graph is
showing us two things in blue we're
seeing the actual emissions of carbon
dioxide and if we go pre-industrial
revolution or the early stages of the
industrial revolution our emissions of
carbon dioxide were very low and fairly
flat and we have seen that they have
gone up dramatically especially over the
last hundred or so years
and that carbon dioxide doesn't just
immediately leave the atmosphere it
stays in the atmosphere for a while so
as we increase our emissions the
cumulative concentration of carbon
dioxide has gone up to those levels that
we just saw before the industrial
revolution or the early stages we were
within that range that we saw over the
last eight hundred thousand years but
then it cumulatively has increased so to
get us to this place that is far out of
that range
and to appreciate what it's doing to our
oceans we just have to recognize that
the carbon dioxide in the air is in
interaction with the ocean actually with
water everywhere so if i were to have
some h2o or water
in reaction with carbon dioxide
that is going to react or can be an
equilibrium to form what is known as
carbonic acid which is
h2co3 if you want to know how the bonds
are structured it looks
like
this
where each of the oxygens are attached
to a hydrogen and the reason why this is
called carbonic acid is it because it
can easily release a hydrogen ion so
this can be in equilibrium with
bicarbonate which is hco3
minus so it's really just our carbonic
acid minus a hydrogen ion plus a
hydrogen ion
so as you have more carbon dioxide in
the air that reacts with water in the
ocean well then you're going to have
more carbonic acid and you're going to
have more of your hydrogen ions the
reaction is going to go this way as you
have more of this stuff and especially
more of the carbon dioxide and we have
observed that in the oceans themselves
we have seen that ocean ph
if we go to the early industrial
revolution it was around 8.2 and it has
gone to 8.1 and you might recognize that
the lower the ph the more acidic it is
but you almost also might be saying hey
that doesn't look like that much of a
change but it actually turns out that ph
is measured on a logarithmic scale so
we're actually talking about powers of
10. so this change if you really want to
get into the math ph is the negative log
of the hydrogen ion concentration and so
the hydrogen ion concentration here
relative to there if we wanted to
compare if we want to see how much it
grew you would say 10 to the negative
8.1 over 10 to the negative 8.2 and if
you look at this analysis you'll see
that this is approximately 1.26
or another way of thinking about it over
the course of the industrial revolution
because of the trends we have seen in
this graph that our oceans are about 26
percent more acidic and to appreciate
why this is a big deal
i will remind you that things like coral
reefs or shells in sea animals these are
formed with calcium carbonate and
calcium carbonate you have a positively
charged calcium ion forming ionic bond
with a carbonate ion and carbonate looks
like
this
which looks an awful lot of what we see
right over here in the carbonic acid or
the bicarbonate and so if all of a
sudden you have a lot more of these
hydrogen ions in the water in dissolved
everything's more acidic now it might
disrupt this process of formation some
of this carbonate might go and nab some
of these hydrogen ions less likely to
form an ionic bond with the calcium it
also doesn't just directly affect things
like calcium carbonate which is
everywhere it's actually the main
constituent of pearls it's the structure
of so many especially rigid structures
in life including sea life it's actually
also antacid tums is mainly calcium
carbonate but this acidity in general is
going to throw all sorts of organisms
off of their homeostasis organisms are
highly highly sensitive to changes in ph
to changes in acidity but the big
picture takeaway a lot of talk is about
global warming and carbon dioxide
concentrations in the air but it's also
not only warming the ocean because of
the greenhouse effect but it's also
making the oceans more acidic which is
having some obvious consequences now and
probably some follow-on consequences
that are we are just beginning to
understand